il ya quinze personnes selon différents
décomptes qui ont perdu l'oeil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le flash-ball c'était une fabrication
française qui ait des années 90 qui
était relativement imprécise qui a été
remplacé par une arme beaucoup plus
précise avec un viseur le lbd40 qui lui
en plus permet d'envoyer des projectiles
plus loin ces armes sont vendues et
vanté comme non létale c'est à dire que
a priori elles ne sont pas faites pour
tuer à l'origine l'idée qu'il ya
derrière ces armes
c'est en cas d'affrontement de
difficulté pour les forces de l'ordre la
possibilité d'immobiliser quelqu'un
parce que vous avez des charges très
forte
et puis vous pouvais plus marcher on
vous vous écroulez etc et il ya des
règles il ya un manuel ce manuel a été
hier matin rappelé par le dgpn directeur
général police nationale à ses troupes
en disant interdiction de viser la tête
des parties génitales
le problème c'est que nous avons
quantité de vidéos de photos de gens qui
sont blessés à la tête
la question que je pose aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que ce chiffre là est due
au seul hasard ou pas est-ce qu'il est
dû au manque de formation est ce qu'il
est dû au fait qu'il y ait des gens qui
ne sont pas formés en maintien de
l'ordre qui utilisent ces armes est ce
que c'est la dangerosité de ces armes
comme le dit le défenseur des droits qui
fait qu' on en arrive là